la neuropatía periférica es una
condición común que ocurre cuando una
lesión o una enfermedad daña su sistema
nervioso periférico con origen en su
cerebro y médula espinal los nervios
periféricos se extienden a su piel
músculo y tejidos
su sistema nervioso periférico transmite
información vital entre su organismo y
el cerebro en la forma de impulsos
eléctricos
existen tres tipos de nervios
periféricos los nervios motores regulan
los movimientos de los músculos
esqueléticos de su organismo
los nervios sensoriales transmiten
sensaciones como el calor vibración
tacto y dolor al cerebro
los nervios autónomos regulan las
actividades de los órganos y glándulas
internas
cada nervio está formado por varias
células interconectadas llamadas
neuronas que transmiten los impulsos a
la velocidad de la luz este intercambio
constante permite a su cerebro responder
a la contribución vital de su organismo
sin embargo el daño a sus nervios impide
este vínculo esencial lo que resulta en
una neuropatía periférica
el daño a un nervio único llamado mono
neuropatía en general se da como
consecuencia de una lesión o un estrés
reiterado un ejemplo de la mono
neuropatía es el síndrome del túnel
carpiano el impacto reiterado al nervio
en su muñeca puede causar cosquilleo
dolor y debilidad en su mano brazo y
hombro
la participación de varios nervios
llamado polineuropatía es mucho más
común
el daño en general comienza en los
nervios más alejados del sistema
nervioso central y avanza en forma
simétrica
la polineuropatía puede ser causada por
diabetes y otras enfermedades sistémicas
infecciones o exposición a sustancias
tóxicas
uno o todos los tres tipos de nervios
pueden verse afectados y los síntomas
son específicos para cada uno el daño a
los nervios sensoriales típico de la
diabetes puede derivar en adormecimiento
de sus manos y pies con menor capacidad
para detectar la temperatura
insensibilidad al dolor
o sobre sensibilidad al mismo
la polineuropatía también puede dañar
sus nervios motores que puede derivar en
debilidad muscular
parpadeo
y dolor
los signos comunes del daño del nervio
autonómico incluyen la intolerancia el
calor pérdida del control de la vejiga y
trastornos gastrointestinales problemas
para respirar y problemas de ritmo
cardíaco
en general el tratamiento de la
neuropatía periférica se focaliza en el
tratamiento de la causa subyacente y
provee alivio sintomático
si tienen una neuropatía puede recibir
analgésicos terapia física para mantener
la resistencia muscular o cirugía para
aliviar los nervios atrapados o
comprimidos
si tiene polineuropatía su médico
tratará la enfermedad subyacente para
evitar más daños a los nervios
le puede recomendar analgésicos para
aliviar sus síntomas
si tiene polineuropatía con discapacidad
sensorial su médico puede recomendar
zapatos ortopédicos para evitar lesión
al pie